[Musique]
qui a un son si tu casses quelque chose je
peux le réparer J'ai une école pour les
jeunes qui sont comme toi Ching nous pourrions
être ta nouvelle famille si tu aimes aller
qureishi
où est-elle
elle devrait être morte quoi qu'il se passe
là-haut fait  elle est plus forte elle change
ce dont j'ai peur quand est le contrôle de mauvaises
choses arrivent aux gens que j'aime je ne
t'abandonne pas G c'est quelle
famille nous prenons soin les uns des autres pour que le pouvoir
[de la musique
] détruise tout ce qui
est jamais venu  en contact avec jusqu'à ce que vous
ne compreniez pas qu'ils craignent
et ce qu'ils craignent que nous cherchions à
détruire avez-vous peur petite fille qui répond
à un homme sur une chaise êtes-vous la créature la plus
puissante de la planète
alors tuez-nous
tous c'est votre  faute Charles dis moi comment
on répare ça Charles dis moi quoi faire
je ne sais pas quoi faire la fille meurt
elle est toujours Jean qui aide encore
parfois ils veulent croire que les gens
sont quelque chose qu'ils ne sont pas prêts le
temps que tu réalises qui ils sont
il est
trop tard  ming
x-men Dark Phoenix dans les cinémas le 6 juin
vous